yeah welcome to this video and I go if I
for a change and we have a CARICOM so
what line let's play the advanced c 5
year i recently am me down a video about
this of course for icc german language
um and this was some presenting this
line for for black ok i only can tell
that i looked at some things that i
liked for black but i don't know um yeah
all possible continuations of course see
takes d5 now 2593 can just um go bag and
i'm not sure that this really are helps
so just take here and then he seeks i
think i think this is even an online so
this is some still ok for me I'm just
spending lots of time here ok so let's
try to simplify this a bit and Queen a
form may be tween a form double attack
so he probably needs to take now
interesting you should be seven look son
looks a bit weird in my eye at least
okay but I'm not very well developed I
need to or get the King out of out of
this black really a weakened the dark
squares a lot so if I'm given some time
Bishop to c5 or if you play c5 himself
attacking the Queen I go Queen a3 and
attack see if I've twice yeah this is a
possibility but let's let's secure the
pawn and Bishop c5 I don't think he
could play c5 Queen a three-room c8 this
is some may be the way to go for black I
don't think it can really allow me to
put the bishop on c5 this is just dumb
this would just be terrible killing is
bishop on d7 galaxy fibers probably am
what black needs to play now okay he
thinks otherwise okay I cannot go g4 and
Bishop pawn to d6 winning material but
I'd also don't need to i mean i just
don't mind to exchange pieces like takes
takes root be aight i mean any endgame
is just down close to lost for black
with the with the bishops here
so g-form G for admission to 26 come on
this really am ties him up enormously go
into to here and then c5 with the
intention to go Bishop to a six maybe at
some point g5 and Bishop a 6mm the
question is um okay let's let's do this
first this is good anyway or let's say
the move okay I could I could I could
have played h3 and maybe this was even
better age three okay what this this
night doesn't have it only has III yeah
okay but first things first if I go
Bishop a six now rook be one Bishop
takes e8 is this the itis it is very
good for white okay let's just do this
keep it simple the problem is that at
the end I will I will be able to UM to
enter here on a seven and as ya hear
some coordination is so bad the bishop
here cannot move anywhere now I've got
Queen I thought Queenie seven but it's
not queen is seven bishops somewhere
I've got queen d 7 hmm
the night has only h2 and III is there
some way to come on this is probably
just enough and 27 next month e 6 hangs
and f8 mate so he needs to play Bishop
f7 and now this move attacks the rook
rook e8 I just takes his six and he
cannot take on a two because of made on
the back rank so he just wait wait wait
wait I come on this is simple taking ten
just take this I'm always thinking about
trapping the night because it only has
got this III square so King e2 or
something but he can take h2 cannot
really trap this piece don't go in here
too and now player c6 next came the
queen bee
7oz was probably even better cannot take
any way because of the background made
ok but I can play it now still cannot
take it's still made Quincy 8 f 8 mid
and after the rook yea tall so there I
can I can play the C porn just c7c 7
coming ok I got another pawn get
probably speculating on on the time but
it's not really difficult to Queen B 7
yeah i think really IDK lot i think the
key moment so is here when he absolutely
needs to play c5 I don't think you can
can do without this so check this
briefly here DM must go see 5 or isn't
this list does this have a big drawback
I thought ok anyway white with the
bishops and so on should be somewhat
better but um jam computer gives me a
really cool advantage I didn't think it
was also clear but
what what what is definitely clear in
the game after this this is just
probably close to lost don't think I'm
you can somehow make a playable position
out of this computers on 1.3 I think
it's even worse really my rugby 3 is
also a good move i have a geforce very
direct and this is just just a disaster
yeah thanks for watching